is going to be fun isn't it
thanks much all right so I've got to
live up to that now and this was meant
to be the fun talk now unlike all my
other ones which apparently no no I
don't know you judge but it is the bunt
talk and I'm going to do the cyber thing
and I didn't realize when I was
preparing this that it would be the
night before the big thing tomorrow in
the u.s. going to work that opportune
and when I was planning on a thought
look I'll do a cyber thing and I
recommend the right person to the cyber
thing not because of my security bits
and pieces but because I come from down
here now in case you don't know what
we're talking about here this is
Australia and we're populated by
convicts right so this is this is sort
of the the the the criminal heritage if
you like and we got to thank you guys a
lot to that because you pick the
absolute worst people possible and you
send them there you took them out of
there thank you very much original
photos of the time of its gets you
account this and you cook took us both
long you put them there we sent you back
Rolf Harris sorry about him but so you
know we got this thing where we've got
this site the Heritage we've got this
sort of criminal heritage helps us think
a lot about cyber and we know a lot more
about cyber lately because this blokes
been talking a lot about
and you're laugh right and everyone
takes the piss out of him because what I
think he really knows much but he does
and I know a lot about acting good we've
established that you know the ladies
he'll tell you how much he knows about
everything to deliver them up there
knows a lot about hacking and if there's
been a lot of hacking lately and a lot
of hacking hacks they're happening
around the election and there's all this
sort of DNC leak stuff where Democratic
National Convention got hacked and all
their data has got leaks everywhere and
all over the place Aaron's sort of
trying to figure out who it is like who
actually cyber hack them and chop it so
he's got these ideas right he says I
reckon I know I reckon I know who could
have been I'm going to quickly rush it
but it could also be China it could also
be lots of other people it also could be
somebody sitting on their bed that
weighs 400 pounds okay because we love
stereotypes in this industry though a
so-so Trump's figuring it out he's going
to solve all the problems and although
in a bit of a think about it and he's
gone all right it's it's going to be as
playful in pounds when he's bed he
doesn't like certain parts of the world
and I got thinking about I thought he
might be talking about this bloke now
this is um this is the leader of the
Democratic not really Democrat against
North Korea and you know he's up there
and Trump doesn't particularly like him
and Trump has said a lot of things about
North Korea in the past and a little
while back here he had some things to
say and you know I was reading about how
he thought they were cyber hacking them
and in Australia there's a word here
that we don't use a lot and I had to
Google norc's and then I got quite
distracted for some time
I'm not entirely sure how they are being
used to taunt I can picture it I can
imagine
incidentally every single tweet and
statement you see from him here I
haven't made up and I know sometimes
it's hard to tell the difference right
but they're all legit so anyway he's
gone all right you know it's China
dimension with us and everyone sort of
just sitting around watching it all
unfold and I think a lot of us are
finding it very amusing as he does this
and Matt many of us was sort of waiting
to see where it goes now look it's it's
fun to take the piss out of Trump and
look we should right I mean it's the
right thing to do aha but that we forget
it's not just him there's then
presidents before him who's had their
issues and yeah I think back to w
remember when everyone took a piss out
of W right because he was kind of simple
a little bit stupid and he was kind of
funny but it's like you look at him next
to trunk now and you go that was so
claim back there but W had stuff to say
about the cyber as well I'm curious and
you have a global to anybody do you use
Google occasionally and one of the
things I've used on the Google is to
pull up mash now the Google is
anonymously useful from anything I used
the Google to figure out what Knox was
among only one so yeah we've got this
bike and yet he obviously had his issues
and I guess we kind of think of W and
chump has been you know if it's
delivered silly but the bloke in the
middle has had his issues as well and we
kind of forget that all of them seem to
have a pretty bad
comprehension on cyber and Obama said
this little while ago it's run country
we do have to make sure that their
computers in a computer age inside
classroom that they work and then
there's internet you gotta have internet
if you cut it's like America one's not
an optic you make it bigger I like
coming here because I can do the
American joke now we're all laughing and
fortunately everything in the UK has
been perfectly normal lately now you
love it but you know that was actually
chumps fault as well and this is not a
fabricated tweet this is real I don't
quite understand it good it's but it is
real so you know they've got their
issues ha I asked one thing about
Australia is we're happy being pretty
self-deprecating involved and look we
know when we look stupid we know when
our politicians look stupid and we've
got this place now this is our Attorney
General and recently he was trying to
explain what metadata is because in
Australia we came up with this idea
because of the convict thing we said
that one day one of you might turn out
to be a terrorist so we're going to save
all your meta done every piece of
metadata that goes through we're going
to save it and then if later on you
become a terrorist we can look at what
you're playing on iTunes whatever no no
no we're going to save it all so this
guy Brandes he's had to explain what
metadata is and he's on the news here
and he has a bit of a shot at it what is
metadata in your view well the metadata
is oh but the metadata is the the call
is initiated but the web address isn't
part of the message
the website with the web address and
this is basically where like after about
half an hour and he he obviously had a
bit of trouble understanding what the
minute after the web address whatever it
is none of us are sure yet because of
this guy but the thing is that we do
need our politicians to understand what
what cyber is and cyber hacking and all
this sort of stuff because it does
happen a lot and you guys have been on
the receiving end of that down here so
you had the talk talk incident a little
while ago and talk talk got very hacked
they've lost a lot of data and
afterwards that they're trying to figure
out like what what happened right like
who broke in and install all their
daughters and there's this statement
that came out and this is Dino Harding
for those who don't know CEO talk talk
and I've come out and going well we
looked into it and we reckon it's
Russian Islamic cyber yardage now this
this is funny but it's true this is
literally what they came out and said
Russian is Linux eye videos it's just
like let's just pick the scariest words
we can possibly find apologies to any
Russians and we'll just chuck them all
together and we'll be good now the
problem is of course that they had to
eventually go alright well we got a we
got to fill out what's happened that
actually do some proper attribution and
they're looking through looking through
the servers they had to go and have a
look through all of the computer servers
you've got to check your computer
service when you're when you're doing
this sort of thing so that you can be
sure where the hacking was and they
going to have the examination so I can
tell the computer serves as a thing I
don't know so the guy through the
computer service and eventually a guy
okay you know we've kind of worked it
out and Dido's out they're doing more
press conferences and things and she's
trying to convince everyone that you
know look it happen but talk talk is
very progressive we're using modern
technology we're moving forward future
yada yada and she's sitting in front of
this this Windows ME computer this is in
2015 which is next to the big CRT TV
sitting on the VHS player and and people
were doing what you're doing right
they're laughing and they're having to
sort of go look it's really not a big
issue everything's fine no drama you
know move on but they did inspect the
computer servers enough to discover who
the culprit was and they found him and
he's just like here and this this guy
has his face obfuscated because it is
actually a child it is not yet legally
an adult but look I mean we all watch
the news we know what hackers look like
so I think we can unmask again aha so
there's this guy and TalkTalk says
alright we've looked into this and we
reckon the whole thing cost us 42
million pounds nice number to choose 42
million pounds and they're going to cost
us 42 million pounds so the penalty
that's going to be handed down to this
guy is we're going to take your iPhone
away like this was the penalty
you cost us 42 million pounds no more
iPhone and he's not allowed to hack
anything for another year because he's
on probation when you're 18 you can
start making [__] again until then no
more so that happened and that all
wrapped up and that was sort of a
TalkTalk act and then then died I was on
TV again last month you would have seen
this I mean we saw this in Australia see
it was in here and she's on TV because
someone has figured out they can get
into all the rouses as they ship
everyone you by the way telcos ships and
really [__] routers out the consumers so
they can get into the routers and they
can get the Wi-Fi password and sonken
drive by a house log in the network so
she's had to come out and they made this
statement made a tweet said look there's
no rest to any personal data they've got
some of their best spokespeople on it as
well it's a trying to make it very clear
and the the actual statement they came
out with is that they cut out this one
and what I like about this is that
they're basically saying you really
don't have anything important anyway
this is not a great deal there now what
this should be reminding everyone is
that cyber is a really big thing right
like it's it's impacting us everywhere
and and Trump knows this as well now the
cyber is so big so the fiber is rigged
ah thank you for clarifying that so I
read the big thing and it's sort of
permeating every part of our lives right
so we're seeing it on the TV the whole
time we obviously live with it
particularly us we're doing the tech
thing for those of us with kids our kids
are getting exposed to side - the whole
time - and they're getting exposed to it
very young and it's interesting to watch
how kids respond to the cyber because we
see we see little kids like this right
now this kid he's trying VR for the
first time which is a pretty cool
experience and his dad's obviously put
him up to it so he has a bit of a go
[Music]
[Laughter]
as the two things I find amusing about
this number one is the kids reaction and
are you or found it amusing the other
one is for dad right but the dad is just
hurt the kid crying any teasing himself
laughing and for those of us out there
that appearance it's like the first time
your kid says [__] you piss yourself
luck and if you are yet to have kids you
have this look forward to the sort the
first time it's hilarious after that my
wife started speaking to me where did
you learn that word oh crap say it and
it is a true story too I got the video
so the kids start learning all this
stuff they get exposed to cyber very
early and sometimes they're sort of
getting exposed to things that we don't
really want them exposed to too young
and it happens very innocently so we had
this kid the other day he was playing
with an Amazon echo this is the little
one and he's like all right you know you
can ask the a coder to play me some
stuff so what will give that a go if you
can say we want to hear a station for
poor dejected portal region girls oh no
no
[Laughter]
okay there's a frame like halfway
through that with a kid is just going
but whatever done day because the
parents it is yelling at at going stuff
so and that there's kind of a party if
it goes this technology is so [__] like
how did it mess that up but I gotta play
this to you again I'm going to subtitle
it and see if you can figure out what
Alexa might have heard so give us
another run because that's exactly what
it sounds like
right and the poor computer has just
done exactly what it's heard but the
thing was that also is that Alexa learns
right like she builds up this this
profile she has to hear these things
somewhere before and my guess is that
it's not the first time elections have
that request
so yeah kids kid get all this exposure
and it's kind of sad in a little way and
that it it makes things very complex as
well because now kids get exposed to all
these things there's so much cyber in
all these different places all gets very
confusing and it all gets a little bit
complicated and Trump knows this right
here like he understands this is on top
of it I think the computers and
complicated lives really
the whole change of computer as menswear
nobody knows exactly what's going on
yeah when I watch this first of all what
he says is funny but the thing that I
couldn't stop watching was the bloke
next to him now this was Don King he's a
boxing promoter he's also a convicted
murderer for trampling on the deaths
will move fast but he is standing there
with this massive grin and a big badge
of Trump and I'm gone what why and I
realize it makes sense because suddenly
Trump looks normal right it's like the
best way to make him look normal is to
get someone who's batshit crazy as
possible and put him next to him so that
is Don King John King is el meanies he's
a fairly normal American blokey has self
defense weapons and things like that
I'm sure to protect his family they all
have them but Johnson sort of guy and
look this actually makes life very
complicated right besides making life
very complicated and I think in many
ways sometimes the other way around
sometimes it makes life very transparent
and we see this with a lexer again in
other ways so there was a case just
recently where someone's had the Amazon
echo in their house and that the police
have gone there some murdering happening
in your house we want to go and pull all
your Amazon echo records because we
think that maybe the Amazon heard you
doing the murdering yes this to me is
for transparency because you can't even
murder in your own home while you have
some time it's not an endorsement it's
just an observation
well you have one of these in there's
like it's not a good idea okay so the
thing about echo as well is it's just
another one of these devices where we're
going let's just add infinite to
everything right let the more Internet
we add to everything the better it will
become and we saw this one pop up the
other day this is a this was an IOT
brush believe it or not this is real
this came out at CES only a couple of
weeks ago I'm not sure why you add
Internet to a brush but it literally got
one of the CES Innovation Awards oh very
happy with it
and you know you look at this and go
what sort of state of disrepair would
your head need to be in to require an
IOT hairbrush
it's a mystery really but we are getting
a lot of IOT stuff the icy hairbrush is
one of a long line of IOT things and so
haven't you think about it I was finding
all these sort of curious eye or two
things there's a really good Twitter
account Internet of [__] and it is just
Internet of [__] stuff over and over and
over again connected things that
probably should never be and I was
having to spin through the list I
thought what I'll do is I'll compress it
and I'll grab sort of ten crazy IOT
things that designs the sort of families
and we'll run through quickly so give me
an example let's say you're out there
dating you're hooking up you want to
keep in touch with your partner while
you're away you get this it's a
Kissinger you both put one on your phone
it's got sensors and motors so I can
feel your lips and it can blow anyway it
can do that stuff that's not what I
meant to say all right so you get your
hook up and then you move into a house
and you get a dog but you got to go to
work you don't want to leave the dog
alone it's bored so you get this which
is a servo which allows you to see your
dog and launch dog food at the dog from
your office apparently we need them now
then you decide that's you know dogs are
one thing you want to have kids but you
got to make sure you swimmers are okay
first so you go and get a yo sperm
tested which you actually plug into your
phone believe it or not not entirely
sure why anyway it's an IRC thing so
that's good you get pregnant and you've
got to do a pregnancy test so of course
you've got to have an IOT pregnancy test
now for those they've not seen these
I've seen them twice but they're very
fundamentally basic devices I'm not sure
what you get from adding internet anyway
you add Internet okay so now you're
pregnant and you have a baby but you
want the baby to be as smart as possible
so you meant to play music to the baby
so there's there's this which which
which is a real thing
google it what one end is connected to
the iPhone bay on so
don't mix them up so you're having the
baby of course when you having a baby
you need to go the bus and the whole
time you get an IOT toilet which will
actually track your movements every
single time you go it has a calendar and
it'll plot them on there I don't know
why it just does it
now remember also all of this stuff is I
I see it's getting synched back up to
the Internet is hitting services or that
sort of thing once you do have the baby
and you're breastfeeding there are I 80
breast pumps as well which connect to
your phone so everything is IOT you have
the baby there r io t nappies this looks
really uncomfortable I don't know why
they did it like that one would imagine
it actually has a battery connected to
it which might make it interesting
aha and then of course you want to get
the kid out of nappies so you go to
potty training so you get an eye pockit
which is a connected potty because
that's where you really want to put your
valuable ipad all right like right in
that vicinity and then because kids get
sick you go and get Akins of smart
thermometer which can take the
temperature you don't put this in their
mouths and that's the real thing too now
all these things they all collect data
they all saw it digitally a lot of them
hid services we all back up to iCloud
and God knows where else they all go up
there into the internet and they go out
through your internet connection which
brings me to you guys so your p.m. has
said because one year might one day be a
terrorist we're going to do this we're
going to see each other so we're going
to save every piece of data that goes
through certainly every website you're
talking to and they're going to know has
the baby got a temperature are we
pregnant pause we being pre natal might
run dog food at the dog get a know that
however don't worry because they're
going to look after your data really
really good and this is what the sign
saying we're going to put all your data
on our computer servers and it's going
to be safe because we're going to be
very careful with it our computers are
safe which brings us back to Trump again
because he has something to say because
I'll tell you what
no computers day I don't care what they
say no
and the alarming bit about this is he's
actually making sense right it is all
concerned about like you put your Darfur
somewhere once it's digital it's it's
fluid it'll move around it'll get cyber
hacked and it will end up somewhere else
now a last thing you want to do is end
on a slide with Trump making sense so
one of the things that we've learned out
of this is that obviously kids are
getting very good at the cyber hacking
we are seeing that having quite a bit
saw the TalkTalk kid bunch of other kids
are getting into trouble too and and
Trump does have a view on how effective
kids are at the cyber so he had Esther
seriously
I have a son he's 10 years old he has
computers he was so good with these
computers it's unbelievable now the
thing is Trump's son is just he's
basically just like any other normal kid
who rides around on his Gold Line in his
penthouse apartment playing with his
stretch limousines or daddy sits on a
gold throne with his supermodel wife
then and this is what we've got to worry
about this is the future so unless we
stop these kids now this is the future
we've got to look forward to and all
that night let's make cyber gradient
thank very much
[Applause]